il n'y aura pas dites-vous de retour en
arrière la révolte est devenue une
révolution le régime Vinci sur quoi
repose encore ce régime est-ce qu'il
repose sur la peur qui depuis 43 ans
contamine la société ankylose et en
dehors les consciences et l'esprit de
révolte ou est-ce qu'il peut encore
compter sur de solides force de
répression alors déjà pour répondre à la
première question Jean-Marie je fais
depuis deux mois et demi des dizaines et
des dizaines d'interviews par semaine en
fait d'Iraniens d'Iraniens de
l'intérieur d'iranienne des jeunes des
moins jeunes toutes générations tous
disent sans exception qu'ils ne veulent
plus du régime des molles donc ce que je
dis là ce soir repose non pas sur ce que
je pense mais repose sur ce que les
Iraniens de la rue me racontent à moi
journaliste
ce régime pour répondre à la deuxième
question c'est un régime qui aujourd'hui
est dans le déni c'est un régime qui n'a
jamais su répondre aux attentes de la
population iranienne depuis qu'il est
arrivé je l'ai rappelé dans le
l'intervention que je viens de faire à
plusieurs reprises les Iraniens sont
descendus dans la rue pacifiquement pour
faire entendre leur voix à plusieurs
reprises les Iraniens ont demandé très
pacifiquement qu'on les écoute ils se
sont fait tirer dessus ils ont été
arrêtés je l'ai dit dans mon
intervention torturé
aujourd'hui la violence les assassinats
le viol qui est aussi l'arme du régime
sont devenus en fait les seuls moyens je
pense de tenir pour ce régime qui est à
bout de souffle c'est en tout cas moi ce
que je perçois dans le cadre de mes
enquêtes et oui je pense que ce régime
aujourd'hui ne pourra pas tenir très
longtemps car on ne tient pas un pays
aussi éduqué que l'Iran à coup de
matraque de kalachnikov et de violence
quelle qu'elle soit
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'un printemps
iranien comme on a parlé d'un printemps
arabe alors c'est une question que on
entend beaucoup actuellement je vais
vous donner ma perception moi je ne
crois pas qu'il s'agisse en fait d'un
qu'on puisse le comparer un printemps
arabe j'ai plutôt l'impression
d'ailleurs que ce sont les Iraniens en
2009 quand un peu inspiré quand même ce
qui s'est passé dans le monde arabe
et je pense aussi qu'il y a une chose
qui est importante l'Iran tout le monde
ne le sait pas mais n'est pas un pays
arabe et donc là la façon de penser des
Iraniens de ces jeunes Iraniens de ces
jeunes iraniennes leur sociologie leur
culture est très différente de celle que
l'on peut connaître dans le monde arabe
que j'aime beaucoup comme vous le savez
Jean-Marie donc c'est très différent
donc je suis toujours gêné par cette
appellation en fait de printemps arabe
qui voudrait nous rappeler ce qui s'est
passé il y a une dizaine d'années il y a
un autre point qui est très important
ces jeunes Iraniens combattent l'islam
politique en Iran il faut se rappeler
que pendant les printemps arabes les
Frères musulmans j'ai couvert les
printemps arabe donc je peux en parler
les Frères musulmans les islamistes se
sont engouffrés immédiatement dans la
brèche des manifestations pour pas
tomber les dictateurs aujourd'hui ces
jeunes iraniennes ces jeunes Iraniens
combattent l'islames politiques et je
crois que ce combat doit nous inspirer
très sincèrement en Occident je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure parce qu'au moment où
l'islam politique s'implante de plus en
plus en France mais pas que en France
voilà la les Iraniennes les Iraniens
sont en train de faire tomber je crois
l'un de ses faire de lance
merci merci à vous la parole peut
évidemment circuler si quelqu'un veut
poser une question à Emmanuel Razavi
pas encore alors nous allons accueillir
maintenant si vous voulez bien madame
azadecchian ah pardon excusez-moi pardon
oui
il y a un bouton rouge et je suis
d'origine égyptienne Franco égyptienne
pour la DOP pour les droits de l'homme
et vous avez fait la comparaison avec ce
qui se passait au printemps arabe
je me souviens 2011 en Egypte donc le
printemps arabe c'est c'est quel pays la
Tunisie et puis le la Libye Égypte donc
les Frères musulmans comme vous l'avez
dit ce sont engouffrés dans les jeunes
qui ces images que vous avez passé tout
à l'heure nous rappelle la place tarir
en 2011
et la prise de pouvoir a été faite par
les Frères musulmans et heureusement
qu'il y a eu la réveil deux ans plus
tard mais le réveil 2 ans plus tard
c'est parce qu'il y avait une armée et
finalement l'armée intervenue maintenant
ce qu'on voit en Iran quel est l'autre
pouvoir face à ces jeunes qui peuvent
les défendre et puis dire bon les mots
là doivent tomber mais qui prend la
place
infiniment monsieur pour votre question
alors j'ai découvert j'étais place tarir
donc je vois tout à fait de quoi vous
parlez j'ai beaucoup couvert l'Egypte
aujourd'hui en Iran c'est une question
qui se pose le rôle de l'armée on a pu
voir en fait certaines vidéos dans
certaines villes en fait de l'Iran dans
certaines villes iraniennes ou des
militaires sont venus défendre de jeunes
manifestants
c'était assez ponctuel on a vu quelques
scènes aujourd'hui parmi l'armée
iranienne de ce que j'entends il y a
aujourd'hui oui des officiers qui se
posent la question du moment où il
basculeront en revanche ils ne sont pas
encore dans ce basculement je pense
qu'ils sont dans l'attente alors non pas
dans l'attente de ce que va faire le
peuple iranien parce qu'il le voit mais
dans l'attente de ce que va faire la
communauté internationale il y a deux
éléments qui sont importants de mon
point de vue mais à travers ce que
j'entends en des témoignages que j'ai
chaque jour c'est que va faire la France
que vont faire les États-Unis deux pays
qui sont extrêmement importants en fait
pour l'Iran deux pays aujourd'hui qui je
crois qui résonne quand même aussi dans
le cœur en fait de ces Iraniens qui
manifestent et donc évidemment dans la
pensée en fait des militaires
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on s'en mêle aux
risques que finalement le régime ne
tombe pas et donc au risque d'être
fusillés que nos familles soient
arrêtées c'est ce que j'ai entendu voilà
ouf il y a une accélération de la
communauté internationale et là à ce
moment à ce moment précis
donc nous allons pouvoir montrer que
nous changeons de camp et que nous
soutenons en fait les jeunes même s'il y
a déjà eu quelques épisodes de la sorte
voilà je sais pas si j'ai répondu à
votre question
merci
madame madame
qui veut poser une question
d'avoir organisé cette coloc ma question
pour compléter la l'interrogation par
rapport à la similitude qu'on peut avoir
avec le printemps arabe il faut quand
même rappeler à l'assemblée que l'armée
iranienne n'est pas l'armée de laïque
fondée par Nasser depuis 43 ans il y a
eu un effort continu pour couper la tête
de l'armée entre guillemets comme nous
on peut l'imaginer ici elle est
remplacée par les forces qui viennent
des passe-parents donc ce qu'on appelle
nous chez nous le sait pas donc il est
aujourd'hui très difficile de pouvoir
connaître ce qui se passe au centre de
l'armée parce que les fortes ont été les
forces ont été fusionnées avec les
milices de la révolution dont les têtes
sont nommées directement par le guide
suprême donc ça c'est une information
importante et je préfère rappeler
l'existence de Monsieur Hussein Borély
qui est le chef de l'état-major iranien
et qui est directement nommé par romeni
donc c'est très difficile aujourd'hui de
penser que l'armée comme à la turque
quoi à la égyptienne pourrait reprendre
le dessus donc ça c'est assez difficile
à envisager mais pour le moment il y a
quelques signaux faibles comme vous
l'avez dit en attendant de voir s'ils
peuvent basculer parce que la communauté
internationale suit au moins on va dire
les officiers de rang inférieur
je partage tout à fait ce que vous venez
de dire Madame
totalement voilà moi je rapporte
aujourd'hui ce que j'entends lorsque je
discute évidemment avec des Iraniens
quel que soit je dirais leur
appartenance y compris d'ailleurs au
sein des milices des gardiens
merci Madame mazaki
vous êtes
sociologue professeur de sociologie vous
êtes directrice du Centre de
documentation et de recherche pour les
études féministes
on vous écoute
merci beaucoup
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs je suis
honoré d'être
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs vous
je suis honorée d'être ici parmi vous ce
soir
je vais
très rapidement faire tout d'abord une
présentation de l'Iran pour ceux et
celles qui
connaissent pas les particularités de ce
pays à savoir qu'il s'agit d'un ancien
empire que donc nous avons une mosaïque
ethno linguistique et religieuse c'est à
dire que c'est un pays multiethnique et
multi religieuse qui s'est constituée
sur plusieurs millénaires
donc c'est un pays qui est effectivement
se trouve à la croisée à la fois de
Moyen-Orient d'Asie d'Asie centrale et
donc de ce fait on l'Iran a beaucoup
aussi
influencé les courants civilisations à
la fois de monde iranien de mon indien
mais également tout le monde islamique
en général donc l'Iran était conquis par
les Arabes l'armée arabe au 7e siècle
donc
l'islamisation de l'Iran a duré pendant
plusieurs décennies voir siècle et donc
la religion zoroastrienne a c'était la
place à la religion musulmane et donc
au 16ème siècle sous les Safavides le
chiisme qui est aujourd'hui au pouvoir
en Iran devient la région religion de
l'État contre l'Empire ottoman qui était
euh le califat sunnite donc je vous
disais l'islam chiite majoritaire mais
il y a aussi une en Islam minoritaire à
savoir l'islam sunnite qui est à l'heure
actuelle très surveillé c'est très
difficile de vous dire combien de
pourcentage de la population est sunnite
puisque ça interdit lors des
recensements de poser cette question
mais selon mes enquêtes de terrain en
Iran jusqu'en 2008
j'estime avant pour cent le nombre des
sunnites en Iran essentiellement
constitué de des Kurdes de baloutes et
des turkmens ce sont les minorités
particulièrement à l'heure actuelle
aussi
réprimé puis il y a environ d'autres
minorités religieuses à savoir justement
les chrétiens les juifs les héros astria
dont le nombre a beaucoup diminué
puisque la population iranienne a
pratiquement triplé depuis la Révolution
alors que le nombre des minorités
religieuses
officiellement reconnu par l'Islam n'a
pas augmenté même à beaucoup diminué
et puis il y a une minorité les baraïs
qui n'ont absolument pas le droit de
citer qui sont particulièrement
persécutés puisque c'est une religion
interdite en Iran
alors c'est un pays qui se moderne nous
Emmanuel Razavi le disait
83 millions d'habitants 75% de la
population iranienne est urbaine et le
taux d'alphabétisation de l'ensemble de
la population et avoisine les 90% c'est
une population relativement jeune disons
par rapport à la France par rapport aux
autres pays de la de la région
les Iraniennes donne naissance à l'heure
actuelle à seulement 1,6 enfants c'est
très important de le constater ce qui
montre aussi la modernisation de leur
comportement démocratique
et en même temps la majorité des
étudiants dans les université Iraniens
sont des étudiantes alors même qu'il y a
un concours d'entrée à l'université la
révolution actuelle doit beaucoup aussi
au réseau sociaux on le sait à Internet
c'est pour ça que il coupe Internet et
donc pratiquement 70% de la population
iranienne selon les statistiques que
j'ai pu trouver sont effectivement ont
accès à Internet disons avait accès
maintenant le permettez-moi de passer
effectivement aux femmes iraniennes
c'est pas la première fois que les
femmes participent à un mouvement social
les femmes iraniennes dès 1906 dès la
Révolution constitutionnelle ont
participé à la révolution sous une
apparence voilée à gauche qui a une
quarantaine d'entre elles a été
d'ailleurs tuée et puis aussi lors du
mouvement pour la nationalisation du
pétrole elles ont aussi soutenu ce
mouvement puis très rapidement je passe
à la révolution de 79 à laquelle
beaucoup de femmes iraniennes ont
participé sans nécessairement avoir des
revendications pour leur propre droit
alors ironie du sort un mois à peine
après la victoire de la révolution et
contrairement aux promesses de Home mini
qui était leader de la révolution le
port du voile devient obligatoire et une
série de régressions sont imposées au
droit des femmes et aux droits familial
ce qui fait que de façon automatique des
milliers de femmes descendant la rue de
c'est l'image à droite contre le port du
voile obligatoire et c'est régressions
bien sûr j'y étais et on a été tabassé
donc je pense que là il s'agit d'une
société moderne d'un côté avec un régime
en face qui est un régime moyenâgeux
répressif corrompu un menu raser il faut
vraiment insister là-dessus aussi et en
même temps
des lois et des institutions archaïques
qui effectivement place les femmes sous
la tutelle des hommes agis qui
considéraient réellement les femmes
comme des citoyennes de ce qu'onzone
j'ai pas le temps d'entrer dans les
tapis en 2009 lors des mouvements verts
les femmes surtout les jeunes femmes
participent à ce à ce mouvement
d'ailleurs n'oublions pas Médard Soltane
qui a été tué lors de ce mouvement et
donc là
femme égale homme était l'un des slogans
de ce mouvement enfin femme les femmes
iraniennes on le sait sont devenus les
enjeux politiques majeurs se sont elles
qui vont
défier qui ont défié ce régime à maintes
reprises et aujourd'hui fort
heureusement soutenu par aussi beaucoup
d'hommes et en particulier de jeunes
hommes après l'assassinat de Gina Massa
mini qui était comme une gousse qui a
fait déborder c'est le vase puisque leur
revendications étaient déjà là et
aujourd'hui les femmes sont au devant de
la scène contestataire et pour la
première fois dans ce pays je pense que
les hommes en particulier dans la jeune
génération ont bien compris que c'est
une révolution des femmes contre l'islam
politique et que tant que les femmes
n'aient pas obtenu l'égalité et bien on
ne peut pas parler d'un avenir
démocratique pour ce pays d'où
l'importance des combats des femmes et
de leur présence dans cette révolution
merci
merci Madame
Emmanuel razaville vous nous avez
beaucoup parlé de répression pour
comprendre vraiment de quoi on parle je
vous propose maintenant d'écouter les
témoignages de d'anciens prisonniers du
régime iranien
mesdames et messieurs tout d'abord je
vous excuse pour bien que il faut que je
parle personne pour bien exprimer et mes
sentiments pendant ce témoignage je
parle à personne
je suis ingénieur en
aménagement du territoire j'ai 45 ans et
depuis mon arrivée en France il y a 12
ans je suis l'un des fondateurs de
l'association l'ami du citoyen qui
organise des formations aux droits
civils
vous me donnez aujourd'hui
j'ai été élevé à Island char dans une
famille nombreuse traditionnelle de 11
personnes
après la Révolution islamique en 79 2 de
mes frères ont été arrêtés l'un après
l'autre à un nom d'intervalle par les
agents du régime tous deux à seulement
15 ans ils ont été emprisonnés accusés
de diffusion de tracts anti-régime
islamiques
a été condamné à mort et l'autre à neuf
ans d'emprisonnement
pour que vous sachiez ce qui se passe en
Iran je vais témoigner de ce qui arrive
à nous et aux personnes qui sont
enfermées dans ces jours
au
bout de national de la République
islamique
ou prisonnier et le Ron demander
avez-vous été torturé
personne parmi les prisonniers n'osent
parler de la réalité des tortures
infligées en prison mais mon frère s'est
levé a dit depuis le 1er jour de notre
incarcération tous les jours on torture
et il a montré au représentants les
marques laissées par les coups de fouet
reçu et les contusions sur son corps
après le départ de représentants les
responsables impitoyables de la prison
ont mis mon frère dans un cachot à
l'isolement ils l'ont violé pour en
faire un exemple une leçon pour les
autres prisonniers mon frère était
encore mineur
mon frère en prison après ce viol il
s'est complètement effondré
psychologiquement
quand ma mère est allée en prison lui
rendre visite et qu'elle a appris ce
qu'il lui était arrivé elle s'est
précipitée en criant au bureau de
assadolor l'autre
de la prison des vignes pour protester
ils ont aussi arrêté ma mère qui avait
40 et quelques années à ce moment-là et
lui ont infligé de terribles tortures
sans que nous ayons aucune nouvelle
d'elle
après un mois ils l'ont ramené en
ambulance dans un sale état sur un
brancard en train de mourir et l'on
déposé à la maison où nous étions ses
enfants de bas âge
ma mère tremblait de tout son corps et
avait beaucoup de mal à respirer
nous les petits enfants on a pensé
qu'elle allait mourir
on l'a donc mise allongé face à la
Mecque respectant les rituels religieux
après quelques mois ma mère peu à peu
aller mieux physiquement mais
terriblement fragilisés mentalement et
psychologiquement
pour se venger à chaque fois qu'elle
allait au mosquées ou à la prière du
vendredi elle a arraché les photos de
Romains
révolution et toutes seules contre
elle a été arrêtée et enfermée à
plusieurs reprises
on a tué mon frère en prison en 1990
encore aujourd'hui on ignore ce qu'il
s'est passé dans la prison et comment il
a été tué
la dernière fois que ma mère a été
arrêtée et en prison à Rome elle a
attrapé la tuberculose à cause de
l'hygiène défaillance de la prison
elle a été privée de soins et les décédé
à 54 ans d'une infection pulmonaire
toujours tous mes frères qui n'avaient
aucune activité politique
Stéphane Jean
politique ont été également emprisonnés
et subi d'autres torture pour nous faire
peur
[Musique]
j'ai été aussi emprisonnée torturé deux
fois en Iran pour avoir tenu un blog
internet et avoir défendu des
prisonniers politiques
le reste des membres de ma famille qui
n'ont aucune activité politique sont
encore en Iran et sont toujours sous
pression et harcelées
ce n'est pas seulement notre famille qui
a subi ce genre d'horrible harcèlement
et de torture des milliers de famille
iraniennes ont subi et subissent
toujours cela et de manière même encore
pire et plus terrifiant
aujourd'hui que je me trouve ici avec
vous c'est même chose terrifiantes
arrivent aux familles de ceux qui sont
arrêtés lors des protestations de la
Révolution
beaucoup de vie sont prises et beaucoup
de familles sacrifiées par injustice
[Musique]
actuellement la République islamique a
arrêté plus de 15000 manifestants et
tuer des centaines de personnes
chaque individu arrêté chacune des
familles des tuées ont une histoire
semblable
et dans mes mots
vous avez probablement vu et entendu que
la majorité des députés iraniens a
demandé l'exécution des manifestants et
ramener lui-même tel un assassin cruel
décide du devenir des êtres humains
innocents
cher député ma question est combien
d'individus on ira doivent être tué
torturés et disparaître
pour que vous et la société mondiale
preniez une décision ferme face à ce
régime terrifiant
[Musique]
nous avons besoin de votre aide pour
être libéré de cette république
islamique sanguinaire avec moins de vie
sacrifiées moins de 100 versées
nous souhaitons que le lourd dossier de
la République islamique soit saisi par
le Conseil de la sécurité et que les
pays
occidentaux prennent la décision ferme
de ne plus reconnaître le régime de la
République islamique comme légitime
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
j'ajoute rien parce que je crois que ça
pourrait être un dessin et le mieux
c'est qu'on vous écoute madame
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames et messieurs
c'est moi une femme qui n'a jamais
accepté le port du voile obligatoire et
c'est pour ça que les agents de la
République islamique mon frappé et
blessé à la tête
j'aurais pu mourir comme la jeune femme
de 22 ans marchant à mini qui a été
arrêté battue et tué parce qu'à leurs
yeux elles ne portaient pas correctement
son voile
oui j'aurais pu aussi mourir mais je
survécu j'ai pris ma fille par la main
et j'ai fui avec elle seule j'ai fui mon
pays pour rester vivante
je me suis réfugiée ici dans votre pays
en France le pays de la liberté
d'expression et des droits humains pour
rester vivante et pour pouvoir être la
voix de mes camarades la voix des amis
qui ont été exécutés
je vais vous raconter un de mes premiers
souvenirs
j'avais cinq ans quand les Gardiens de
la Révolution ont arrêté mon père
mon père était bel homme un grimpeur et
mérite bien bâti avec une moustache bien
fournie noire mon père était mon héros
ils ont ramené mon père à notre petit
chez nous pour fouiller et saisir des
documents contre le régime
mon père avait les mains menotté par
derrière sa chemise blanche était hachée
de sang je voyais les pieds de mon héros
tremblait
mon père a voulu me caresser les cheveux
mais ses mains étaient menottées ils ont
ramené mon père avec eux ils ont ramené
mon héros avec eux
accusé d'avoir écrit un poème contre le
régime j'avais 22 ans quand on m'a
arrêté pour mon interview télé à Voice
of America
je suis une autrice mais avec toutes mes
œuvres interdites de parution en Iran
une autrice avec des collègues auteurs
qui se font exécuter en
irani
je ne suis pas venue ici seulement pour
parler de ma vie je suis ici pour
témoigner du meurtre de la vie en Iran
depuis la Révolution islamique dans mon
pays il tue la vie l'amour le chant et
la joie dans mon pays même s'embrasser
est un interdit
couche de chaude Nico
j'ai plein de voix qui résonnent dans ma
tête la voix de Nico tu es à 16 ans elle
voulait devenir chanteuse
la voix de sorino tu es à 17 ans elle
aimait les mathématiques
la voix de David 27 ans exécuté David
s'est battu jusqu'à la dernière minute
pour retrouver sa liberté
[Musique]
la voix de Back toch poète et l'un de
mes proches amis
back toch n'était pas peureux comme moi
back toche ne s'est pas enfui
il est resté et il est mort en prison
dans la voix des femmes emprisonnée qui
se font torturer et qui hurle de
douleurs c'est
la voix des jolies filles qui se font
violer en prison
en réalité je n'ai pas le courage ni la
force de vous dire ce qu'ils font aux
femmes dans les prisons de la République
islamique ni comment il les viole
imaginez la pierre version
fermez les yeux et écoutez-moi avec
votre coeur
imaginez la France occupée par l'ennemi
et que vous êtes obligé de vous enfuir
de quitter votre pays
imaginez qu'on vous a invité au Sénat de
ce pays et on vous demande d'être la
voix de vos compatriotes durant 5
minutes
durant ces 5 minutes je pourrais être la
voix de qui de quelle peine quelle
douleur
mesdames messieurs dans mon pays ça fait
43 ans que le peuple se bat il se bat
pour des valeurs pour lesquelles la
France s'est battue
Mira
j'aimerais que vous sachiez que votre
vote sera très important pour sauver des
vies l'autre femme
au moment de voter je vous prie de
penser aux femmes aux enfants aux jeunes
Iraniens aux jeunes qui sont tués et
exécutés chaque jour en Iran
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en Iran
n'arrive même pas en temps de guerre
dans les autres pays
l'arrestation des collégiens et lycéens
chez lycée
à l'hôpital et des dizaines d'autres
agissements qui sont interdits même en
temps de guerre
man Martin
corboni Autriche et poétesse réfugiée
dans votre pays je vous demande de
l'aide le régime de la République
islamique est un régime terroriste ne
négociez pas avec ce régime reconnaissez
officiellement la révolution du peuple
iranien mon hardeline
nous avons le droit de vivre en liberté
égalité fraternité en votant contre la
République islamique vous pouvez sauver
la vie de tous ceux qui sont en train de
se battre pour la liberté
soutenez le peuple iranien l'histoire ne
s'écrit pas par les dictateurs elle
s'écrit par le peuple et le peuple
iranien vous demande votre soutien et
votre Être
soyez notre voix femme vie liberté
[Applaudissements]
nous accueillons monsieur hirbotte
dégagniazar qui est avocat
qui est avocat en droit international
c'est lui qui entre autre coordonner le
soutien à Nasrine sotoudé sa construire
iranienne défenseur des droits de
l'homme qui a toujours été persécuté par
le régime et puis nous accueillons aussi
son confrères en même temps monsieur
Richard cedillot qui lui aussi est
avocat en droit international et
spécialisé sur la question des droits de
l'homme merci
bonsoir et merci de cette invitation
c'est très difficile de prendre la
parole maintenant
déjà sur les pour les qualités je rends
à César ce qui appartient à César le
spécialiste du droit international et de
l'autre côté de la barre
je ne fais que qu'assister et je vais
vous expliquer un peu ce que j'essaye de
mon petit niveau de faire pour
de faire pour me rendre utile alors on
m'a dit d'être très bref
je sais je sais pas faire plus ah j'ai
oublié le petit pour le
qui est sur la table
je vais essayer alors j'avais préparé
une intervention assez
dans un temps peut-être un peu plus
structuré je vais essayer de vous donner
des marqueurs pour faire bref et donc je
suis je vous prie d'excuser ce propos
s'il est un peu déstructuré mais je vais
essayer d'aller à l'essentiel pour
pouvoir laisser le temps à la salle
après de poser des questions déjà un
marqueur personnel je suis arrivé en
France à l'âge de 10 ans en 1981
et je ne peux pas ne pas profiter de
cette
de cette salle et de cette audience dans
cette maison pour ne pas remercier ce
pays d'accueil qui m'a permis d'avoir
une vie sereine j'étais venu passer
quelques semaines de vacances en
attendant que mon père qui nous avait
accompagné à la frontière participe à un
renversement bah ça fait maintenant
depuis 1980 je suis là et il n'est
jamais venu nous rejoindre donc
ça c'est le marqueur personnel je suis
avocat à Paris je
suis ancien monde du Conseil de l'Ordre
et membre actuellement du Conseil
national des barreaux et à ce titre
depuis mon implication à l'ordre
peut-être un peu avant tu fais peut-être
de ma spécialité du mois de menace
spécificité de ma langue
j'ai gardé un contact avec les confrères
iraniens et notamment au moment du
du drame qui a vécu notre confrère
nassrine setudet à différents niveaux à
l'époque Richard était au CNB moi
j'étais au barreau de Paris on s'est
coordonné et on s'est fait ce qu'on
s'est mieux faire les avocats ça veut
dire les portes paroles et on a essayé
de garder le message et d'avoir une
information c'est un peu ce qu'on essaie
de faire aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir garder ce lien avec les
confrères un slogan que je pense réel
les oublier c'est les condamner
donc
un deuxième marqueur à ce titre
d'ailleurs je vais vous lire tout de
suite un message que Nasrine a très
court message que notre frère mastering
surtout les qui ne pouvait être présente
avec nous alors elle est condamnée mais
un signal de à domicile et l'aurait bien
souhaité mais c'est assez aléatoire
internet pour avoir des contacts et
pouvoir organiser
elle nous écrit et donc c'est une
traduction libre pour vous je suis
profondément reconnaissant aux
consciences éveillées qui ont déclarant
leur solidarité avec le soulèvement
femme vie liberté font entendre nos voix
en Iran et permettre au peuple iranien
d'espérer pouvoir profiter un jour des
avantages de la démocratie
l'histoire n'oubliera jamais un tel
soutien Nasri
un deuxième marqueur plus personnel que
je vous donne pour comprendre peut-être
la spécificité de l'Iran et le caractère
résilient des Iraniens et pour vous
montrer que 6 ans sont là aujourd'hui
c'est que la résistance
dure depuis un certain nombre d'années
en réalité
vous savez Richard pourra peut-être vous
en parler
il a fait un petit film il a participé
avec un collectif où on voyait des
actrices se couper les cheveux c'est un
sens symbolique pour nous ce symbole il
nous vient du champ nommé le livre de
fèves aussi qui a été créé dans les
heures dans l'an mille c'est-à-dire pour
400 ans après avoir été où l'islam s'est
installé pour créer une résistance une
spécificité c'est pour ça que les fêtes
iraniennes fêtes païenne existe toujours
les faits anciennes existent toujours et
ce Guy sous borum c'est-à-dire ce fait
de se couper les cheveux symboliquement
qu'on voit il faut que vous compreniez
la symbolique c'est le rituel
de la mort de farangers
qui farine 10 je suis toujours entre les
deux langues c'est un peu pharyngué
c'est le problème des GDJ et des j en ma
collé moi 2h mon prénom à mon nom de
famille que je n'avais pas donc des
pharyngis dans le champ nommé donc c'est
important ce symbole est important c'est
pas simplement de se couper les cheveux
c'est que ça nous renvoie notre histoire
ancestrale et à notre culture qui est
une culture autonome de résistance et de
résilience
un deuxième message pour vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui
ici on s'organise on est plein de
collectifs moi j'ai la chance au niveau
je suis de d'être membre du Conseil
national des barreaux et de participer
donc à faire voter des résolutions pour
la défense des confrères je vais rester
sur ce domaine de des droits de l'homme
des droits des avocats des droits à une
justice équitable des droits une vraie
justice de la Défense et de des gens des
manifestants et de l'arrêt des
condamnations à mort qui sont devenus
une arme de
une arme réellement de répression de
manifestants
j'avais un beau développement sur le
sujet je vais vous les je vais pas vous
le donner je vais tout simplement ce que
je n'ai pas le temps par contre je vais
vous montrer ce qu'on fait on est à
plusieurs collectifs à travailler
ensemble ce travail a été fait par un
collectif d'artistes dont l'un des
membres
s'éteint donné ce qui est venu au
Conseil national des barreaux pour
remercier la profession d'avocat pour
tout ce que nous faisons pour soutenir
les confrères faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
en Iran quand vous êtes avocat et vous
allez défendre quelqu'un vous êtes
assimilé à celui que vous défendez et
donc vous vous retrouvez vous même en
prison pour les peines les plus graves
c'est l'article jeux de souvenirs
43 de la constitution du code pénal qui
dit que à partir du moment où vous êtes
sur les crimes les plus graves vous
n'avez pas le droit de choisir librement
vos avocats vous êtes obligé de choisir
sur une liste d'avocats
quand on sait le contexte général où la
pendaison a été appelée de ses vœux par
un nombre important de personnes
à l'Assemblée au parlement iranien alors
la grande majorité je crois que c'est
200-77
qui ont voté ça bah vous imaginez dans
quelle situation se retrouve les gens et
pourquoi tout le monde va dans la rue
alors je sais pas voilà ce genre de
choses que nous faisons celui-ci est
beaucoup plus visuel que notre travail
que nous faisons dans un autre collectif
avec Richard il vous en parlera plus
ce genre de choses c'est de répertorier
jour le jour alors on n'est pas les
seuls à le faire et c'est important de
que vous le sachiez de remonter il y a
par exemple aussi sur papier cet ouvrage
qui est fait au jour le jour chaque jour
on voit grâce aux réseaux sociaux ce qui
se passe et
on fait des témoignages on écrit on
écrit les lieux on écrit les noms les
noms on écrit les causes et on envisage
et on espère on compte beaucoup sur
cette future résolution pour nous donner
les moyens de pouvoir de rendre justice
à toutes ces personnes là vous avez 60
enfants
d'âge différents qui ont tous soit été
abattus par balle soit son décédé suite
au coût qu'ils ont reçu et qui n'avait
rien demandé d'autre que pouvoir vivre
librement et peut-être pour certains
même traverser la rue
je pense que ça va être beaucoup plus
parlant que de vous faire mon
développement sur ce que nous faisons et
sincèrement aujourd'hui
le message que je vais vous faire passer
c'est n'hésitez pas à liker n'hésitez
pas à montrer que vous êtes là derrière
vos ordinateurs derrière vos vos
téléphones parce que de l'autre côté ils
le savent et ça leur donne de l'énergie
je vais laisser et pas aller beaucoup
plus longtemps je vais laisser Richard
peut-être terminer sur les actions
concrètes qu'on essaye de mener parce
qu'on est là pour tenter de ça mais
sachez que il y aura un alors révolution
j'ai deux questions alors je vais y
répondre tout de suite
allez-y poser des questions
donc moi non plus si la première est-ce
qu'on peut encore dialoguer avec l'Iran
et si oui comment alors j'aime beaucoup
cette question c'est pour ça que je
voulais vous me la poser parce que vous
me posez la question de dialoguer avec
l'Iran
et pas avec les Iraniens ça dépend de la
définition qu'on donne à l'Iran on peut
dialoguer avec l'Iran parce que c'est un
pays complexe avec des populations avec
des des
cultures complexes et il ne faut surtout
pas hésiter à travers les réseaux
sociaux quand vous avez des doutes quand
vous avez besoin de parler avec
quelqu'un quand vous vous étonnez quand
vous voulez faire partie de faire part
de votre solidarité quand vous lisez
quelque chose vous avez des petites
choses comme google trad vous écrivez en
français vous écrirez en perçant un peu
mauvais mais ça leur fera plaisir donc
dialoguer avec les Iraniens dialoguer
avec les gens que vous avez de l'autre
côté qu'il ne reste pas anonyme et que
vous ne restez pas anonyme pour eux
c'est déjà le premier point
et alors la deuxième question évidemment
donc on a compris qu'il fallait se
mobiliser sur les réseaux sociaux
exprimer notre solidarité mais plus
concrètement qu'est-ce que la communauté
internationale est plus particulièrement
les instances politiques françaises et
notamment les parlementaires peuvent
faire pour aider les Iraniens
j'aurais aimé que ce soit l'Iran aussi
cette fois-ci
ce qui peut faire c'est de ce qu'on est
en train de faire ce soir parler de nous
faire écho de ce qu'ils font recueillir
l'épreuve
faire tout ce qui est prévu tout ce qui
a été dit depuis le début c'est-à-dire
sanctionner les coupables dire qu'il y a
une justice après qui a un lendemain
avec une justice donner des horizons aux
gens qui sont là-bas et pourquoi pas moi
je suis dans l'utopie je sais qu'il y
aura des difficultés mais je rêverais
une saisine de la Cour pénale
internationale par la France qui aurait
saisi le Conseil de sécurité pour
pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre des des réels
derrière sanctions maintenant j'ai une
casquette qui est peut-être une
casquette un peu différente dans ma
pratique quotidienne j'ai une casquette
de médiateur je fais beaucoup ça je suis
désolé que la France ait décidé au mois
d'octobre dernier fin de 6 octobre
dernier d'envoyer un ambassadeur en
France alors que tout le monde
faisait partir les ambassadeurs mais
chiche maintenant cogner qu'il servent
qu'il servent réellement à la diplomatie
et qu'il soit l'acteur d'un dialogue et
que le porte-parole de la France est des
libertés et qui soit un peu courageux
sur ce point-là je l'avais prévu un
extrait de du Dictionnaire de Diderot et
d'Alembert de 1751 qui donne la
définition
historique de ce que doit être la
médiation en France et qui était la
leçon de l'école de de la diplomatie
française qui a été un peu oubliée je
vous lirai pas parce que c'est un peu
long mais je vous invite à aller le voir
c'est très intéressant et c'est parlant
et chiche puisque vous avez envoyé un un
émissaire et que aujourd'hui c'est un
diplomate français qui a qui vient de
prendre fausse bah qu'il est le courage
de porter une voix courageux et de
demander à ce que cela cesse et
participer comme ça a été fait dans
d'autres pays peut-être sous l'égide de
la France à un dialogue et pouvoir
peut-être faire sortir toutes ces
personnes qui sont dans evil et qui sont
des activistes qui sont en prison mais
qui ont aussi une voix qui ont aussi des
choses à dire
merci j'ai fait le plus rapidement
possible
[Applaudissements]
et bien je vais également essayer d'être
rapide et
de structurer ma pensée même si devant
le raccourcir je vais probablement
échapper à ce que j'avais imaginé vous
dire complètement
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la
question iranienne alors que je n'ai pas
la chance d'être iranien lorsque j'ai
entendu parler du sort qui était réservé
à notre concurrentoudé alors que j'étais
membre du Conseil National des Barreaux
condamné en tout à 38 années de prison
et 148 coups de fouet
le barreau français sachez-le est très
attaché à la défense de ses confrères
qui à travers le monde ou que ce soit
sont menacés et je crois pouvoir dire
que c'est probablement l'un des barreaux
ou le barreau au monde qui envoie le
plus souvent des observateurs pour
assister à des procès ou pour venir en
aide sur nos confrères qui sont menacés
je pars en quelques jours au Gabon pour
défendre un confrère ça n'a pas de lien
avec l'Iran mais qui est lui-même menacé
en d'autres circonstances
c'est pour nous une tâche essentielle
j'avais donc proposé que le portrait de
nassrine soit apposé sur la façade du
Conseil National des Barreaux boulevard
Haussmann un grand immeuble et
l'assemblée générale de conseil avait
voté cette idée et j'ai été heureux
évidemment que la présidente décide de
couvrir l'entièreté de cette immeuble
avec ce portrait ce qui a eu je crois un
effet considérable qui a pu être de
nature aussi à la protéger herbode le
disait à l'instant très bien il l'a fait
lui-même pour le barreau de Paris à
l'époque et
la notoriété nous le savons fort
heureusement peut participer à la
protection de ceux que nous souhaitons
défendre et c'était la raison de ce
mouvement et puis nous avions déposé
également à recours devant une instance
des Nations Unies mais il est évident
que que son sort était déjà extrêmement
connu alors aujourd'hui
ce qu'on peut faire juridiquement la
situation est difficile pourquoi parce
que vous le savez
l'Iran est une véritable dictature de
sorte qu'elle ne ratifie pas les
instruments internationaux qui
pourraient éventuellement permettre
de mettre en œuvre des procédures
destinées à protéger les victimes
l'Iran à ratifier ce qu'on appelle le
pack international relatif aux droits
civil et politique qui est un instrument
très important mais n'a pas ratifié le
Protocole facultatif qui nous
permettrait de saisir le comité des
droits de l'homme de l'ONU de requête
individuelles ces regrettable mais c'est
évidemment volontaire de la part de cet
état comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
nous pouvons saisir le groupe de travail
des Nations Unies sur la détention
arbitraire qui lui reste compétent mais
qui rendra un avis probablement très
intelligent comme il le fait
habituellement
mais qui évidemment ne sera pas
contraignant comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer
le droit français ne permet pas d'agir
devant les juridictions françaises sur
le fondement du crime de génocide ou
même du crime contre l'humanité commis
commis en Iran
alors nous avons imaginé éventuellement
que nous pourrions peut-être déposer les
plaintes sur le fondement de la
Convention contre la torture je vais pas
vous faire un cours de droit mais
l'avantage de cette convention c'est
qu'elle porte une véritable compétence
universelle ce qui veut dire que les
juridictions françaises ou anglaises ou
belge ou italienne sans compétentes pour
connaître des crimes de torture quel que
soit la nationalité de l'auteur quel que
soit la nationalité de la victime et
quel que soit le territoire du pays sur
lequel le crime a été commis alors c'est
un énorme avantage évidemment la seule
condition c'est que le tortionnaire se
trouve sur le territoire
ou la plainte a été déposée
au moment de son arrestation tel avec la
France si une plainte est déposée en
France la France n'aurait pas le droit
d'aller le chercher dans un pays tiers
d'accord et la France ne pourrait pas
non plus demander son extradition mais
en revanche nous nous sommes dit mais
pourquoi ne pas inviter et je
souhaiterais que le Sénat travaille sur
cette question qui a les moyens que nous
n'avons pas forcément pourquoi ne pas
faire en sorte que dans tous les pays au
moins européens soit déposer les
plaintes contre ces tortionnaires pour
les empêcher
définitivement de voyager dans quelques
pays démocratiques que ce soit et nous
avons déjà des renseignements et nous
avons déjà
grâce au travail absolument cas qui a
été fait
nous avons déjà des noms des noms de
victimes mais également des noms
criminels je peux vous assurer que ça
aurait un impact immédiatique et
juridique considérable alors on en a
parlé parce que a eu lieu il y a il y a
peu de temps le Congrès mondial contre
la peine de mort à Berlin et nous avons
évidemment beaucoup parlé de l'Iran
ce que la peine de mort à laquelle nous
sommes évidemment tous profondément
opposés
a toujours été appliqué scandaleusement
en Iran à l'encontre des majeurs des
femmes et même des enfants
et nous savons très bien aujourd'hui
parce qu'elle est une arme politique
contre les mains des mollas nous avons
très bien que de très nombreuses
personnes arrêtées de façon complètement
arbitraire vont être condamnés à mort et
probablement exécuté
c'est la raison pour laquelle le Congrès
s'étendrait et l'association Ensemble
contre la peine de mort qui
organise ce congrès fait partie d'une
plateforme qui s'appelle impact Iran et
elle travaille considérablement sur ces
questions qui réunit de nombreuses zéonj
iraniennes qui je pense travailleront
aussi sur ces questions de torture et
j'espère que nous pourrons avancer je
peux vous annoncer aussi que nous avons
rédigé un mémoire un recours qui va être
signé par de nombreux institutions
d'avocats le Conseil National des
Barreaux le barreau de Paris la
Fédération nationale des unions jeunes
avocats le Syndicat des Avocats de
France
l'association des conseils d'entreprises
et la Conférence des Bâtonniers et
l'Observatoire International des avocats
en danger en centre contre la peine de
mort ces associations vont signer ce
recours qui va être déposé devant le
Rapporteur spécial sur l'indépendance
des juges et des avocats
vous allez me dire pourquoi les juges et
les avocats et pourquoi pas les autres
alors les rapporteurs spéciaux ont déjà
été très très alimentés l'information
parce que nous sommes avocats et que
nous avons souhaité saisir ce rapporteur
auquel peut-être pour l'instant beaucoup
d'ONG avaient moins pensé et c'est
normal
parce qu'un nouveau rapporteur a été
désigné et est entré en fonction
et parce que le sort qui est réservé à
ses avocat est absolument épouvantable
pour deux raisons je me dépêche je vous
promets je me dépêche pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que eux-mêmes à titre
individuel sont arrêtés torturés violées
en prison comme tous ceux qui le sont
mais on les arrête aussi pour ne pas
leur permettre de défendre ceux qui ont
été arrêtés et notamment ceux qui ont
été condamnés à mort et ne pas leur
permettre d'exercer le recours l'appel
qui doit être en principe formé dans les
20 jours de la condamnation je dis un
mot enfin sur la résolution des Nations
Unies qui doit être présenté jeudi aux
Nations Unies qui appellent qui décide
notamment d'une enquête internationale
il faut absolument que cette résolution
soit soutenue notamment par les
parlementaires français excusez-moi
non vous avez été court et on est en
cours vous avez répondu à toutes mes
questions ce qui nous permet de
rattraper un petit peu la pendule et
peut-être on va on va pouvoir écouter le
le prochain témoignage qui va être très
impressionnant puisqu'il s'agit du
témoignage de sherine evadi que vous
connaissez évidemment tous qui était
aussi avocate et qui a été prix Nobel de
la paix
et c'est en visio conférence pardon
est-ce que vous nous entendez
bonsoir madame
alors on ne vous entend pas
[Musique]
qui était assassiné par la force par les
forces de police
ce qui a déclenché les
restants protestations à ce jour aucune
suite n'a été donné à cette plainte
or de journalistes qui ont pris une
photo de cette jeune femme à l'hôpital
et
qui ont publié un reportage sur son
enterrement dans la presse iranienne
[Musique]
dans le gouvernement
laisse le meurtre sans puni
et considère le journaliste comme un
délai très précis
dans ce pays
[Musique]
de leur vie leur opposition au régime en
place
le nombre de victimes
lors des protestations récentes n'est
pas clair
car l'État ne publie aucun chiffre
aux informations délivrées par les
familles
et après vérification
par des organisations des droits de
l'homme
que des chiffres minimaux peuvent être
un
lors des récents affrontements au moins
460 personnes
ont été tués par le régime à ce jour
traduction parmi lesquels il y a au
moins
enfants mineurs
c'est ce qui a incité l'UNICEF
à faire part de son indignation face à
cette violence
le nombre précis des arrestations n'est
pas plus certain
mais je peux affirmer de façon certaine
que plus de 17000 personnes ont été
arrêtées lors de ces protestations
d'après une publication officielle de la
justice iranienne
à ce jour 10 condamnations à mort ont
été prononcées
dont l'une
à l'encontre d'un chanteur de rap
la violence de l'État s'est étendue même
aux hôpitaux
des patients blessés lors des
manifestations
sont
identifiés et arrêtés par la police
en cas de résistance de la part des
membres du personnel hospitalier eux
aussi font l'objet d'arrestation
il y a même eu un cas
ou
des gaz lacrymogènes ont été diffusés au
sein de l'hôpital
la liberté d'expression
est bafoué à tel point en Iran
que lors des dernières protestations 17
avocats
se sont vues arrêtés simplement pour
avoir défendu leurs clients
certains d'entre eux ont pu être libérés
contre des cautions importantes et
attendent d'être jugé
et d'autres sont encore en prison
de même des dizaines d'écrivains et de
journalistes sont arrêtés
ils sont en prison simplement pour cette
exprimer et avoir fait des révélations
sur des sujets dans le gouvernement ne
souhaite pas entendre parler
des efforts entrepris par le peuple
iranien lors des dernières années pour
des réformes et pour une amélioration de
la situation ont été vains
aujourd'hui
le peuple se soulève depuis le mois de
septembre
pour changer ce régime
la devise de ce soulèvement et femme vie
liberté
ce slogan à deux versants
d'une part il rejette la théocratie
mais d'autres pas
c'est qu'il exprime clairement de façon
positive une inspiration un régime
démocratique et laïque
conditions sinequanone de son
accomplissement
les pays européens
notamment le gouvernement français
peuvent être rassurés que l'avènement
d'un tel régiment en Iran
engendrerait une baisse considérable des
tensions dans la région
une baisse de deux demandes d'asile
en raison d'une sérénité dans cette
région la violation des droits de
l'homme
et ses clientes en Iran que le Conseil
des droits de l'homme de l'ONU
a voté
le 24 novembre
par une nette majorité
la création d'une mission spéciale pour
enquêter sur la répression meurtrière de
ces protestations
hier
le porte-parole du gouvernement a
déclaré
qu'il ne collaborerait pas avec ladite
commission
ce qui n'est nullement une surprise
quand la mesure où cela fait 11 ans
que l'Iran
n'accorde pas de visa au rapporteur
spécial de l'ONU sur les droits de
l'homme
tout ce que je viens de dire
ne donne qu'un aperçu de la situation
actuelle en république islamique
dans ce contexte le peuple iranien
demande à l'état français
de ne pas soutenir le régime de la
République islamique
c'est qu'en réaction à la répression
sanglante
qu'il renvoie l'ambassadeur d'Iran
et que les relations politiques entre
les deux pays se limite
à des rapports consulaires
aussi
nous demandons
aux représentants du peuple français
de reconnaître le corps des Gardiens de
la Révolution comme terroriste et de
prendre des sanctions contre lui je
rappelle
que d'après la Constitution
le rôle de ce corps est exclusivement de
protéger le système de la République
islamique il n'a pas de lien avec
l'armée régulière qui assure la défense
des frontières
de nombreux jeunes
ont perdu la vie pour la liberté et la
démocratie en Iran
ne permettez pas
que le peuple iranien soit encore plus
ennuyé
nous vous serons reconnaissants
de vous placer du bon côté de l'histoire
je mets fin
à ma prise de parole en vous remerciant
à nouveau
et je suis disposée à répondre à toutes
questions
merci merci Madame
merci Madame et d'avoir pris le temps de
ce témoignage
pour je crois qu'on court toujours un
petit peu après le temps donc pour
conclure en tout cas les questions je
crois qu'il y en a une moi qui me qui me
tarde depuis le début on parle beaucoup
de répression on parle beaucoup de morts
on parle beaucoup de torture de quoi
parle-t-on exactement de crimes contre
l'humanité
oui alors je devais pas
vous faire un cours je vous rassure sur
le crime contre l'humanité et sa
définition ce sera un petit peu long
il ne fait pas l'ombre d'un doute
aujourd'hui que
l'ampleur des crimes commis à l'égard de
la population
cette ampleur est constitutive d'un
crime contre l'humanité
le crime de génocide pourra
éventuellement être discuté notamment à
l'encontre de la population du Kurdistan
et du ballothistan il n'est pas
impossible à mon sens lorsque des
informations complémentaires nous aurons
été données que l'on puisse considérer
qu'un crime de génocide avec une
attention de destruction d'une partie de
la population
était constituée en l'état et en
revanche à mon sens il ne fait
strictement aucun doute sur l'existence
d'un crime contre l'humanité au sens
notamment du traité de Rome porte en
création de la Cour pénale
internationale même si celle-ci ne
pourra malheureusement être saisie que
par le Conseil de sécurité puisque
l'Iran n'a pas ratifié ce traité merci
Maître
je crois madame que la conclusion vous
appartient madame indique Lyon vous êtes
présidente de la délégation au droit des
femmes et à l'égalité des chances entre
les hommes et les femmes
merci beaucoup
votre magisté Votre Altesse Royale chers
collègues sénatrice et sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs je veux commencer
par remercier l'ensemble des
intervenants qui se sont exprimés avec
courage ce soir au Sénat c'est un
véritable honneur pour moi de conclure
cette conférence que le président Bruno
Retailleau et moi-même avons souhaité
dédié au courage du peuple iranien et
plus précisément à celui des femmes de
ce pays qui au péril de leur vie se
battent chaque jour depuis plus de deux
mois contre le régime
permettez-moi de remercier tout
particulièrement Bruno retaillod qui est
à l'initiative de cet événement nous
formons une équipe dans le département
de la Vendée je connais la force de son
engagement la sincérité avec laquelle il
le porte et la solidité de ses
convictions qui ne sont jamais à
géométrie variable vous pouvez compter
sur lui vous pouvez compter sur nous
comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
nous parlementaires français affirmant
que les femmes iraniennes ne sont pas
seules et que nous les soutenons dans
leur combat héro et héroïque elles ne
sont pas seules d'abord parce qu'elles
sont soutenues par le peuple iranien
avant de liberté historique souffle
aujourd'hui sur l'Iran hommes et femmes
réunis pour défendre leur liberté
fondamentale et leurs droits depuis la
mort athéhéran de Macha Amini le 16
septembre 2022 trois jours après son
arrestation par la police des mœurs
iranienne pour une simple mèche de
cheveux qui dépassait de son voile des
milliers de manifestants et manifestants
iraniens risquent chaque jour leur vie
pour défier le pouvoir en place et
défendre leur liberté en premier lieu
celle des femmes au péril de leur ville
les Iraniennes arrachent et brûlent
publiquement leur voile symboles
d'oppression par le régiment place je
salue la dignité la force le courage de
ces femmes que rien ne semble pouvoir
arrêter comme vous madame monsieur qui
avait témoigné tout à l'heure la
contestation populaire c'est aujourd'hui
transformée en un mouvement
révolutionnaire dirigé contre la
théocratie au pouvoir en Iran
c'est toute la jeunesse iranienne qui
défie le pouvoir des bols là la jeune
génération ne se bat pas pour une
idéologie mais tout simplement pour la
liberté et pour la vie les
manifestations et émeutes qui ne cessent
de prendre de l'ampleur dans le pays
depuis plus de 2 mois on fait des
centaines de morts et entraîner des
milliers d'arrestations arbitraire vos
témoignages ce soir confirment la
violence et la répression par le pouvoir
en place nous les avons entendues et
écoutez ils nous oblige ses témoignages
le régime faire régner la peur des mise
à mort la torture les passages à tabac
les tirs à balles réelles sur des
manifestants non armés en pleine rue le
régime tue la police iranienne n'hésite
plus à entrer dans les unes universités
pour réprimer les étudiants soupçonnés
d'apporter leur soutien à la lutte pour
les droits des femmes
ces universités où les filles sont
aujourd'hui plus nombreuses que les
garçons plus nombreuses oui pourtant les
femmes et les filles en Iran sont
toujours considérés comme des citoyennes
de seconde zone par le pouvoir en place
leur persécution perdurent ainsi depuis
de nombreuses années les discriminations
et les humiliations envers les femmes
sont nombreuses les droits des femmes et
des filles sont continuellement bafoués
la loi et les pratiques de la police des
mœurs en attestent pour mémoire là je
l'égale du mariage pour les filles est
toujours fixées à 13 ans les pères
peuvent même obtenir des autorisations
pour marier leurs filles à un âge encore
plus jeune le port du voile imposé par
la loi et synonyme de harcèlement
quotidien
d'invibilisation des femmes de tes
tensions arbitraires et d'actes de
torture de la part des Gardiens de la
Révolution
la discrimination se retrouve dans le
droit pénal puisqu'en Iran les filles
peuvent être condamnées à mort dès l'âge
de 9 ans contre 15 pour les garçons
désormais la contestation gagne tout le
pays il ne s'agit plus seulement de
dénoncer les atteintes aux droits des
femmes c'est tout un régime et ses abus
qui sont remis en cause ce soir je veux
témoigner de mon admiration de notre
admiration devenant le courage de ce
peuple qui se soulève ces femmes et ses
hommes exemplaires préfèrent mourir
plutôt que de vivre dans un pays où
leurs droits fondamentaux sont niés si
les femmes iraniennes ne sont pas seules
c'est aussi parce que des voix s'élèvent
dans le monde entier pour les soutenir
comme nous tous si c'est ce soir vous
tous et toutes mesdames et messieurs
mais aussi les sénatrices et sénateurs
qui sont là dans la salle et qui
relayent d'ores et déjà depuis un
certain temps tous ces messages que vous
avez exprimés ce soir pendant cette
conférence je la première en Nathalie
Goulet Marie Mercier j'ai vu tout à
l'heure Joël guerriot mélam Valérie
Boyer et d'autres elle se Joseph voilà
vous laissez natrice et les sénateurs
sont à vos côtés
la délégation au droit des femmes que je
préside et le Sénat tout entier sont au
côté du peuple iranien
contestation était à l'origine un
mouvement féministe tourné vers la
défense des droits des femmes iraniennes
il sait très vite transformé en un
profond mouvement de contestation du
régime autoritaire iranien pourquoi
parce que lorsque les droits des femmes
sont bafoués c'est la société tout
entière qui est bafouée ce sont les
droits humains qui sont niés défendre
les libertés et droits fondamentaux des
femmes ça se battre pour une société
égalitaire et respectueuse des
différences la force de la révolution
populaire qui s'est mise en marche ne va
pas et ne doit pas s'arrêter elle
débouchera je l'espère sur la
construction d'une société iranienne
plus juste dont les principaux piliers
seront la liberté et la laïcité
la communauté internationale si elle est
vraiment attachée à la défense des
droits des femmes et des droits humains
doit envoyer un signal fort et unanime
pour soutenir le peuple iranien comment
accepter par exemple que l'Iran soit
toujours membre de la commission de
l'ONU sur la condition de la femme le
Canada et les États-Unis se sont déjà
prononcés pour une exclusion de l'Iran
de cette commission une hyusienne
qu'attendons-nous la France doit
exalement et également l'exiger vous
avez formulé mesdames et messieurs des
demandes des propositions je vous cite
nommé et condamner ces terroristes des
vis sur les visas des condamnations leur
envoi de l'ambassadeur la reconnaissance
du crime contre l'humanité toutes ces
propositions nous devons nous en emparer
je souhaite quel prospère je souhaite
que la communauté internationale agit
collectivement pour mettre fin à la
répression les exactions à l'encontre du
le peuple iranien doivent cesser la
France doit soutenir toute initiative
coordonnée au niveau européen au niveau
international pour y parvenir enfin pour
conclure comment ne pas évoquer la
situation des femmes afghane
désespérément seule face au régime
talibans la communauté internationale ne
doit pas faiblir dans son combat contre
l'obscurantisme des talibans femme vit
liberté aux doses de la des slogans
au-delà des déclarations il faut agir
l'engagement et la détermination du
peuple iranien nous oblige alors si je
peux me permettre je vais reprendre ce
magnifique geste de madame qui est nous
a fait un très beau témoignage tout à
l'heure femme vit liberté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]